the queen of rock and roll Tina Turner
has died she died at the age of 83 in
our home near Zurich her publicist has
said Tina Turner of course one of the
legends of the music business with hits
like What's Love Got to Do With It
Private Dancer and the best has passed
away at the age of 83. she of course
became famous with uh first husband Ike
Turner and the Ike and Tina Turner
review through the 60s and 70s but then
I went on to have a very very successful
solo career selling more than 180
million albums and getting 12 Grammy
Awards as well as three decades of sold
out Stadium tours had publicist says but
she has passed away after a long illness
at her home near Zurich and her family
and friends have asked if their privacy
can be respected at this time of course
this news just coming into us here at
Sky and the tributes will start pouring
in for Tina Turner queen of rock and
roll who has died peacefully today at
the age of 83.